we're here at the scottish combine in
indianapolis joining us now the general
manager of the super bowl 52 champion
philadelphia eagles he is howie roseman
it just occurred to me you go by howie
does anyone in your life call you howard
you know it's funny you say that there's
only one person in my whole life whoever
called me howard your mom my grandmother
and she passed away a couple years ago
it's um
nobody else does you know my first
interview in the nfl was 1999 with the
new york jets and i was interviewing for
a personnel job
and uh coach parcells walked in and he
mike tannenbaum at the time was the pro
director and he says coach parcells and
why don't you meet howie roseman and he
said howie he looked me up and down and
he said there's only one other howie i
know and he's six four two seventy five
you may wanna go with howard for now
anyway this nfl thing's gonna work out
great for me
that's great
well the nfl thing has worked out great
for you thank you very much you got the
super bowl ring and you've had two
playoff appearances since then and you
guys have shown so much grit and
toughness late in the season
to turn it around when your backs are
against the wall we've seen it two
straight years now
is it also frustrating though you get
yourself in that position every year
where you have to scratch and claw and
fight to get a playoff spot yeah mike
it's funny that you mentioned that
because that's been a little bit of our
emphasis this off season like can we not
put our backs against the wall can we
get in a position where we have a little
wiggle room where we can take a deep
breath where it's not every game
from week 11 and 12 on is playoffs or
bus and because it puts so much pressure
on on the football team and the stress
level increases and there's only so much
you can take with that
and as you see like the world champions
when we won the super bowl we had to buy
it's very hard when you put that much
stress on your football team to then go
in the playoffs and come out at the end
so i think that's been a big offseason
focus for us how can we start better you
know what can we do to improve the
health of our football team
and we've kind of gone in that direction
here with some of the off field moves
that we've made since the season has
ended yeah i mean where where you guys
have a interesting offseason here as far
as you know pending free agents things
like that you know where does it all
start where is it where does it go here
for howie roseman and the eagles well i
think it all starts with the quarterback
yeah and uh we have a quarterback that
we think um is a tremendous player
tremendous leader and so we got to make
sure that he's protected first and
foremost and we put so much investments
into our offensive line that we're
really excited about the offensive line
we have now we we have an important free
agent there as well and somebody's been
a great player for us um hall of fame
jason peters you're talking about for
sure right and then that he's got
playmakers at his disposal always
looking to surround him with playmakers
you know we did last year adding miles
you know jj in the second round who were
expecting you know him to take a big
step up big jump from year one to year
two you know the year before we drafted
dallas goddard so we have him and zach
right um but we want to make sure that
when we look back on carson's career
we've done everything possible to
maximize his success and of course we
have an offensive head coach yeah that
doesn't hurt either right
has carson won silence the downers or is
it still to be determined for him to
really reach that potential where he's
regarded as a franchise guy without
anybody saying yeah but yeah but yeah
but
yeah i think internally that's never
been an issue for us you know he's a
tremendous player he's a tremendous
leader he's a tremendous person and
i think for us we got to do whatever we
can to make sure that we put in a
position to be successful and in my role
that's important it's to make sure that
he's got everything he needs to be
really successful now i don't want to
short
the fact that defense also matters to
that because if you have a great offense
and you're getting leads and you can't
protect those league you can't rush to
pass or or prevent big plays that's
going to hurt your football team as well
so um i think we got a lot of errors
that we're looking at to try to improve
and like you said you know the positive
is
over the last three years you know we're
one of only four teams to make the
playoffs all three years and i think
we're the only nfc team over the last
five years to win a super bowl so you
know we've had a lot of good things but
we're hungry for more
like the one thing okay like me being
johnny evaluator here like the deep
threat that was missing right and you
know desean jackson of course getting
hurt really affected that last year
which i i felt like affected your whole
offense to to a degree
you know you know what you know you
talked about some of the young receivers
you got
you know deshawn he's getting up there
in age i mean you think you're going to
be a big player in free agency as far as
that that position is concerned well i
think you got to look at it as the
off-season in its total picture so you
got to look at what's good and free
agency what's good in the draft how it
matches your picks and and what's the
strength of the draft what's the
strength of free agency um and also when
you're talking about having a young
quarterback like you look at it you know
our tight end group is young um our
running back group we drive to miles
last year even jordan howard who
required and trades 26 years old boston
scott who's the nfc offensive player of
the week against the giants you know
he's tremendously expressive so i think
ideally when you look at it you'd like
to balance kind of veterans and youth um
but i i think also when you talk about
that and having guys who can take the
top off yeah i mean it goes without
saying speed helps it helps at every
level um whether you're talking about
offensively or defensively
you're in a division that has three new
head coaches this year
um that's got to be an advantage when
you i mean because all due respect i
mean mike mccarthy's won a super bowl
ron rivera's been in the super bowl joe
judge who knows how it's going to go but
you've got three coaches breaking in new
programs with new teams it has to give
the eagles a leg up doesn't it
it's it's funny you mentioned that
because i remember in 2002 we played the
bucks in the championship game and john
gruden was in his first year coach in
the box and i'm saying who in their
first year coaching a team goes and wins
the super bowl so
i i think it's hard to make those
proclamations they came into philly in
the last game at veterans stadium and
beat us you know i think we got to focus
on how we can improve our team the
things that we can do better and you
know the first goal is to win the nfc
east but
um we're not satisfied losing in the
first round of playoffs winning the nfc
and losing the first round so we got to
compare ourselves to the teams that are
winning the super bowl you know our
ex-head coach andy reed just won the
world championship in kansas city
they're going to be a threat going
forward so we're we're trying to measure
ourselves against the best teams in the
nfc um in the national football league
because that's where we want to go how
much time do you spend thinking about
how differently the playoff game would
have gone if carson wentz plays the
whole thing
you know i think it's more you feel bad
for the kid and and just um
the amount of preparation he puts in
each week the amount of leadership he
showed when he took over our team you
know at one point we're five and seven
we lose to the dolphins you know
everyone's writing us off you know all
our top three receivers are out and um
everyone just followed him and so you
know just getting the opportunity home
playoff game to play you feel bad for
him but i've learned that that it's hard
to spend a lot of time thinking about
the what ifs it could just drive you
crazy
what if no
let's do it it'll be great um you're one
of the best in the business at your job
you really are and mike and i both
i have not said that to everybody um but
i do feel like this is just uh
am i overstating that i feel like this
is one of the bigger offseasons i've
seen the eagles have i know they're all
big but like here the list of free
agents i got in front of me damn you got
a lot of them like you got a work cut
out for you i just
do you see it like almost like you gotta
flip the team over here are we about to
do that well i i feel i feel two parts
of that i think the first part of that
is every off season is important yes i'm
not trying to downplay the significance
of this off season it's the most
important because it's the next one
right um but at the same time we've been
preparing
for kind of a flipping of our team yeah
we knew that um
when we kind of started back in 2016 and
coach peterson came that we were gonna
have a window right and then the last
couple of years we were trying to extend
that window so we were trying to find
undervalued veteran free agents because
that's where we thought sure margin was
at that point in time that veterans
weren't getting what other guys were
getting right and so as we and we only
had 10 picks the last two years and a
lot of those picks were because we were
trying to win a championship not only in
2017 but in 18 and 19. and now as we
build we look at it as a new period of
time where in 2020 2021 we may have a
lot of new players on our team but we
also have this core group of guys right
that are guys that are under contract
that are big parts of our team i mean we
talk about the offensive line i mean we
have
really you know four guys four starters
who are under contract for the
foreseeable future plus we drafted a
left tackle in the first round um you
know carson's under contract mile is
under contract both tight ends are under
contract now fletcher cox who with all
due respect to the rest of our defense
maybe our best defensive player under
contract for the long term definitely
yeah um i think that we look at it like
let we're we're not in a rebuilding mode
well i know you're not schooling right
and we're gonna do whatever we can
to try to build this team but also to
sustain success we don't want to be in a
period a year or two from now where
we're tearing it all down right
you know you've got your quarterback for
well into the future
do you kind of sit back and look at all
the quarterbacks you're going to be free
agents all the teams are going to be
looking and say thank god we don't have
to jump into that game of musical chairs
or do you kind of wish at some level
that you had a chance to like that'd be
kind of fun to have a ticket to this
party no no thank you you know because
everything and it goes into the draft
like as sure as you can be
until someone
moves into that city is surrounded by
the coaching staff is accustomed to the
surroundings that go with it it's a risk
and so when you know when you're around
someone and that's why we do as much as
we can when we hire new coaches when we
bring new people in to try to find
people who've been around them so we
take some of the guesswork out of it
because
it's a little bit like dating until you
you really live with someone you only
see someone on their best behavior and
you don't really know how they act and
we know our quarterback and it's funny
because somebody asked me at my press
conference i said you know what do you
think it would take to go from seven to
one and i said
i i don't i don't know well guess and i
said well who's the player you know
what's the evaluation of the player you
know what are the other options yeah we
love answers without knowing the details
give me all the information and maybe i
can help out a little bit right okay
here's what do you do with a guy like
malcolm jenkins
eagles coach there's a timely pass by
there right there see that you see that
he's driving him running into the
linebacker you see that that was that
was a little revenge we're late for this
right he tried to get coach peterson to
sit in the middle he declined to do it
did he yeah well he knew it was my seat
he knew he was like that's chris's seat
i can't do that no man quarterbacks
don't do that back up quarterbacks don't
do that
quarterback
it's like this fraternity they all have
i didn't realize it until you know he
came on our staff and hired frank and
they got this like a little fraternity
you can't get in there yeah you can't go
what was the question i wanted to ask
you about malcolm jenkins though yeah
i'm just amazed and you just your
thought process because of what you do
in your job i mean here's a guy that's
been a staple of your defense obviously
a great leader
but for lack of a better phrase kind of
wants to hold you guys hostage this year
for more money or what he feels is fair
market price yeah and we understand i
mean malcolm's a great player and a
great person and at the end of the day
you know he wants to do what's best for
him and we have to do what's best for
the philadelphia eagles um
but i think one of the things that i
that i appreciate about our players is
that we're able to have honest
conversations with them that doesn't
mean we always agree and i'm not talking
about just malcolm
right and sit down and try to find
solutions that work for everyone and
that doesn't always work um and at the
end they we have a job to do and
responsibility to our coaches to our
players to our owner to our fans to do
what we think is right for the
philadelphia eagles
so uh scouting combine they're making
changes yeah workouts at night what do
you think about workouts here we go this
is this the floral headline let me see
if i can get a headline
and get howie fine
because he doesn't like him
i got the headline bill parcells saying
that you should go buy something out
there
no we're asking everybody or at least
when we think of it right the workouts
are at night now what do you think about
that i i this is my 20th scouting
combine and what i'm excited about is
to see the change you know sometimes new
is good it's fun to see that we're
flipping our schedule because you get
it's it's like it's like pavlov we're
class conditioned when we come to andy
this is our schedule this is what we do
this is how everything's going and uh
the newness the freshness of it it's
exciting to kind of see how it goes and
um to see what kind of good food we can
kind of sneak into the dome for dinner
at night oh that's good that's a good
one i like that thanks well the
restaurants thursday friday and saturday
night are not going to be pleased no
you're right during the prime hours
where they would be full right you guys
are going to be at the door maybe the
takeout business that's that's not going
to say he's going to be sitting there
eating a steak on the third row of the
the stadium
all your years being in the business
there's another one we've kind of asked
you know a few guys here
like
most memorable
like workout you've seen from you know a
rookie prospect anybody that jumps out i
mean i'm sure fletcher cox is amazing it
doesn't have to be an easy show
but um you know that david young clowney
type workout where you're just like whoa
i'm there you know i when i think about
it i think about some of the individuals
when we go and we get on a plane and we
go travel and visit with these guys and
when you mention the best workout yeah
you know i go to carson you know i
remember that we we had done a
quarterback tour you know maybe one of
the five best moments in my career you
know we all get on a plane and we go and
uh we we go to california and work out
jared and
kevin hogan and then we go to north
dakota and see carson
and as he was just warming up it was
like it was like a gazelle and just like
he's just kind of floating through it
and i remember he's just kind of
casually like through the workout and he
just he's just like effortlessly talking
about 50 50 yards i remember seeing
coach peterson and just going
whoa like it was just like no effort and
so i think right there we kind of said
this this guy can play in philly right
he's going to be able to throw it in
every kind of condition and so when i
think about great workouts i think of
being up close with the guy because
you're still you're still
you know you're not on the field with
these guys you're not at eye level and
sometimes you can feel a guy you can
feel a guy's explosiveness when you're
down on the field yes
you can it does make it different it's i
like just being here just to see some of
the guys walk by me right just to have a
good feel for okay i've seen him on film
and oh he's this big of a person here in
person i don't get another chat that's a
change
there's no doubt he's always checking
him out and especially the butts and
legs yep that's why i like fletcher cox
whole lot of butt and leg in that
uniform i know that we're going in a bad
direction
so uh can you do sims like button
and i got another one for you and this
won't create a headline this is just
curiosity that we've been asking several
guys about
what if the
draft came before free agency would you
like that
i'll tell you what i was a young gm and
we had this in 2011. and that would be
awesome it was not a great experience
for for the philadelphia eagles or me
personally you know um i think i i i
think the way it is now is is a great
way and that was the dream team vince
young said so
the dream team please i'm a freaking
sorry that's right sorry i'll say sorry
for my texas alum my friend vince young
sorry
yeah but you know some guys want it some
guys have said they want it kyle
shanahan wants it i think sean payton
has said that they would like that that
you can go out and address your needs in
the draft whatever's left over
yeah yeah i know you will all right last
thing just because he's the man of the
moment like patrick mahomes i mean i
know you weren't like evaluating and
thinking about like but just through the
process because i know you're a guy that
probably studies the top quarterbacks
every year no matter what i'll tell you
what though it's interesting because we
had just traded up for carson the year
before right and so i can honestly tell
you i didn't watch any of those top
three quarterbacks after the draft right
until after because i didn't want to
waste the time spending two hours three
hours on each guy
knowing that we didn't have that amount
of time yeah but you know it just gave
me another opportunity to congratulate
coach reed you know and a guy just who
um i came into the league with and is
just a tremendous person a tremendous
head coach and
if it's not going to be us you know it
was the first super bowl i ever watched
uh that we weren't playing in that i
actually was rooting you know and that's
no disrespect to coach shanahan and john
and the san francisco 49ers organization
but um
that that that's our guy yeah right and
so
um he deserves it yeah good for him all
right well hey uh you deserved it and
you got it two years ago and maybe
you'll get it i picked you to go to the
super bowl this morning so did i yeah
thanks for letting me down don't do that
this year okay maybe we got a better
chance
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports